[Music]
and with a little more than two minutes
left in the game the football hi pig
skins are down by three
these are the moments that all-american
QB Connor Lane lives for
Connor Lane is down and he's not getting
up
[Music]
it looks like the team doc is on the
field
this could be devastating for football
texas and texas football
you should probably start warming up
[Music]
hey you okay Connor I can't feel my feet
yeah but are you okay okay I concur he's
just had his bell rung needs to stretch
out you could call doc I Bobby have him
up he can't get up ah both his legs are
broken he needs to go to the hospital
find your own [ __ ] don't talk back to
me I know what's good fam huh
we need your buddy two minutes left give
what you're left in that tank I don't
know I mean it looks and feels like my
legs are broken
[Music]
if he doesn't get up he can find himself
a new dam Connor this is the biggest
moment your life I couldn't look myself
in the mirror and shave I'll let you
throw it away
come on this will get ourselves a win
what do you say let's go come on I can't
stand right
I'm ready coach it's the biggest moment
of your life son take off a uniform
[Music]
now call me a causa dang dang we should
have found that man - you should have a
trick up his sleeve
no 45 whoa Nelly do
[Music]
you